here's a piece of sales advice i give my
18 year old neighbor i walked in on my
18 year old neighbor when he was taking
a sales call i listened to him and he
hung up the call and i was like did you
close the deal i already knew he hadn't
closed the deal i was like no i think he
said he's gonna think about it why don't
you think i'm closing deals and i was
like dude have you heard you you sound
like a stoned 18 year old i was like no
one's gonna buy from you he's like dude
you need to learn how to sell well how
do i learn how to sell and i thought
there for a second just joined my sales
team we'll show you how to cold call
we'll show you how to close 12 months
later kids making 200 000 a year as a 19
year old you actually have to learn the
skill and the only way to do that is
through volume before we join my company
he was taking like one or two calls a
day as soon as he joined with us he was
doing 200 dials a day 100 times the
effort hundred times the result have to
get lots of reps in where you suck so if
you have the opportunity to go and get
lots of reps from somewhere sometimes
it's great to be an employee because
those are the skills that build the
foundation to do what you want to do
eventually